how many a month listen her story has
not that he's got a bunch have you heard
that new song freaky now it's good
he's a like they've sampled like a
recorder it's like detuned it's pretty
funny dope but they like somehow turn
into a dope song okay he's got 13
million that's massive um travis has got
like 26 so he's like double travis is
like though that's crazy though sicko
Mo's 622 million plays that's [ __ ]
insane that's crazy
look at pose I'll post this he's come on
bro
48 he's number I think he's in that 48
million that's insanity
billion right yep rockstar has one point
four billion plays dodging the [ __ ]
royalties on that shower that tank god
dude one point four billion dat that dog
yeah that's like a that's just on
Spotify to Apple music probably is like
1 billion that came out when last year
sometime huh no they
beginning of last year yeah before that
thanks not for a couple years has it let
me let me look up the release date
that's [ __ ] that's wild no beginning
of last year I think was on beer bongs
let's see let's see let's see let's see
you know what it is it's it's all about
the [ __ ] sophomore album Dawg it came
out 2018 really yeah last year a billion
and a half plays in like a year that's
[ __ ] nuts I think that's how that's
how that happens yeah solid summer
release yeah yeah so it's a
make-or-break moment it really is no
weird it that happens cuz dude it I mean
people are quick to shut you off man but
you know they get they like high
especially with music yeah I'm that
picky you know that guy was doping to
put us from my eyes away yeah I like I
try I try to change my attitude in that
capacity I try to give artists the
benefit of the doubt and like if they
have like what's a flop for me I try to
tell myself like well you know creative
[ __ ] doesn't always land you got to give
it another chance but not everyone else
is gonna do that yeah you know and it's
the other thing that's crazy to me is
even like even with infinite access to
music I would do you think most people
have like complex playlists what do you
mean like I feel like I meet people and
they listen to like 20 or 30 songs a
year you know I'm saying what do you
mean
like I'll meet I don't know like I'll
talk about music you heard of this
person they go no you know like and
maybe time talking to people who are
like mid-20s or you know later like and
I see it on Twitter you know like people
like the double XL freshmen list came
out and there's these tweets like
blowing the [ __ ] out the being like um
who are these people
it's like gnar mosey like [ __ ] dudes
who are have been around for a minute
and like are definitely coming up and
like one tweet being like you are so out
of touch if you don't know who this is
and that tweet had less retweets than
than the other one it was like a
majority of people didn't recognize
anyone the double XL freshmen
it's cuz they only listen to [ __ ] rap
genius or like the hip-hop playlists on
whatever rap and caviar yeah that's what
I'm their idea of hip-hop is rap caviar
that's what I mean it's like I feel like
the average person doesn't have like a
complex like playlist or or anything
that is like that they put together like
hip-hop is like like it's the biggest
genre now so you it's the new pop music
so only willing to look into it as much
as they would a mainstream genres yeah
so they just hear whatever's on the
radio they hear the red caviar playlist
but yeah they're not like doing they're
not like on worldstar like looking at
the new videos yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh and and that and like hip-hop is so
much like pop now like yeah you know a
lot of [ __ ] is melodic and you know
auto-tune and so it like it replaces I
feel like a lot of the top 40 [ __ ] no no
no no that's all I was gonna say nav was
talking in that video about like he he
was listening to people and when he
heard someone using the auto-tune
correctly he'd make a note of that he'd
be like they use autotune correctly you
can't hear the auto-tune changing the
note like they're still sitting there
good at singing you can tell you can
tell they're using on a tune but you
can't hear it switch you can't yeah
something like t-pain [ __ ] yeah and I
like and a bunch of my friends have said
that too like Devin was like I don't
like the way that you use autotune I
don't like how much auto-tune is on your
voice and I get like comments too yeah
like on the newest song of people being
like way too much auto-tune good but I
[ __ ] love that sound of like the
pitchy
yeah like h-bonding on locals-only like
the way we use it like full retune speed
yeah yeah if you like it like I mean I
think it depends I think you got to do
it a certain way
I mean t-pain I would say I would say
t-pain uses it correctly he'll like he
hits the notes yeah yeah okay he has an
incredible voice yeah a boogie is like
as like a dude you know okay yeah I've
swerve in his [ __ ] yeah and little Tracy
he uses the same way he's like yeah hole
reaching speed just goes for it I think
I think it just depends you know I
definitely I love the
sound of that I think auto-tune as a
sound for younger people is it's like a
thing that they're like used to and they
like to hear it
I definitely think that's a sign of
someone who is looking older like
there's some about auto-tune that like
really puts off people after late like
the late twenties they [ __ ] hate it
they don't get aired at all you know we
could you know we could pick we'd like
but like we are the guys young people
like weird cuz I'm 21 exactly and I'm
like I'm 20 yeah so it's to us it's like
yeah it's totally yeah no it's more
dislike all we've known cuz we weren't
even row around like when people weren't
using auto yeah I've never heard
anything without auto-tune yeah I've
never listened like Celine Dion yeah
like that now I've never listened to
like any like basic at like just you
know R&B and never let's not you know
tons of black street and I've never
listened
[Music]